[Music]
chris hemsworth shows off his pipes and
reveals his unexpected first job it was
a truth while the Jonas Brothers shared
deets on their reunion and Joe's epic
bachelor party we had the cops on the
first night calling us three times it
all went down on Wednesdays Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon Chris was up first
and he did not disappoint sharing
never-before-seen footage of himself in
costume as fat for onset of Avengers end
game we all have a sense of pride a bit
of sweet quality to it because this is
the last time this gathering on this
group that people is gonna be here
together later in the episode Chris
played true confessions with Jimmy and
Kumail Nanjiani long before he was an
acting superstar he revealed he used to
do this my first job was cleaning out
dress pumps I would have a toothbrush
will spray and wipe
and dried milk covered in him I'm gonna
say you lie I would say like to it was
the truth the Jonas Brothers were also
on the show oldest broke heaven revealed
his five-year-old daughter Alena almost
blew the band's cover before the world
knew about their reunion she did tell
her entire school that you know the
Jonas Brothers are coming back before
the Jonas Brothers were we was trying to
keep it a secret for basically a year
Kevin comes home and says guys Alena
told her whole class those five year
olds and tight-lip our relationship as
brothers as family comes first makes
this a lot more fun and and we enjoy the
ride a lot more lots of exciting family
milestones for the guys recently middle
bro Joe tied the knot with wife sophie
Turner last month and clearly he had an
epic bachelor party in Ibiza we had the
cops on the first night calling us three
times
Joe ripped off his shirt shouldn't
happen in a nightclub took the cardboard
box for 1942 the tequila and somehow cut
it into a bandana
so it just said 1942 across his forehead
I'll dream a true